Oh what is going on YouTube now recently
I read a post about something quite
disturbing once again at an institution
of higher learning we are faced with
this again for those of you who haven't
heard on the Duke campus of eternity
named Sigma imma bust a cap in your ass
decided to throw a racist Asian
fraternity party called Kappa Sigma
Asian prat all that racism biases [ __ ]
like her own turn to tell you to come
dressed up as an Asian person go oh my
god in Ghandi hold me back
hump back down herro and change you
that's all you got [ __ ] you are the
sorriest racist on earth it's not even
shake you dumbass if you don't mop the
language do it better
ha thank you I'll crack your head with a
bottle of sesame oil you badly people
came dressed in Asian rice farmer hats
and little Asian roads worst racist on
earth let me tell you something if you
wanted to dress up as an Asian person
you should have died to hear yellow pun
that [ __ ] and wore a shoddy suit and
that [ __ ] would have made a lot more
sense but instead you dressed up as
chun-li and Raiden step your game up
player I'm not even kidding you I swear
racist people are running out of [ __ ] to
do well we got the blacks and Mexicans
let's go for the Asians man [ __ ] you
said which way scared of a [ __ ] what
time we ain't got good vision or wait
[ __ ] you've seen a kung fu
movie before man I will Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon the [ __ ] out your pants
take my big ass and float on a tree
branch like this I'll smack yourself up
now even you stop speaking Vietnamese
[ __ ] you think we gonna do [ __ ] we're at
the population on this earth but then I
ain't gonna hurt you I'm a bear your
daughter in a pregnant hood with my
agency then I'm gonna take our Asian
baby teach about Asian language give
them an Asian name so you can never
speak to your grandchildren ever come
here come the granddaddy [ __ ] what's
your what's his name
oh yeah I know I don't know a week do
you watch Discovery Channel
we train Tigers but you know what time
is each's Abad white people oh my god
honey look at that it's bigger but this
just in crazy quite okay eating my chi
girl seeing that this fraternity thought
that they could do to cover up the
tracks was to change the name to
international relations that's the best
you got man what you think Asian people
gonna be like oh my food if they change
the name so much better he's soaked a
pet dragon normal anger okay help oh yes
we want everyone to dress
internationally to represent their
culture half-naked white [ __ ] is
wearing random hats is not representing
the Asian culture get dunsack a whale
[ __ ] a lot of people go ahead and blame
racism on ignorance but guess what it
doesn't make it okay
personally I'm at that point in age now
where I am sick and tired of people
using ignorance as a crutch for social
injustice it's 2013 and we still have to
deal with [ __ ] like this well guess what
world
get your [ __ ] [ __ ] together
I'll kidnap you [ __ ] and drop
you off in the middle Koreatown see how
far your job goes oh my god where are we
oh you in Cordia calm now she's icky